[Musique]
début 1940 le canada est en guerre
depuis l'invasion de la pologne par les
nazis en septembre 1939 le premier
ministre williams lines inc andy king
sait qu'il devra envoyer des troupes en
europe occidentale car les allemands
vont l'envahir
mais kenzy king a déjà demande a
derrière lui non consécutifs mais cette
élection-là en mars 1940 ne sera pas
comme les autres c'est une élection de
crise il a besoin d'un mandat fort pour
conduire l'effort de guerre il fallait
d'abord l'appui du québec
pour mackenzie king pour les libéraux
fédéraux depuis les années de wilfrid
laurier l'appui du québec et la clé
mackenzie que jouissait d'un très fort
appui au québec ce qui peut sembler
surprenant c'est un ontarien de la
région de kitchener complètement
unilingue anglais mais il avait le bon
sens d'avoir un lieutenant québécois
sous lequel il s'appuyait ernest
lapointe députée du bas-du-fleuve
ministre de la justice vraiment l'homme
fort du cabinet le grand frère ou le
petit frère de mackenzie king qui se
fiait à lui pour tout ce qui concernait
le canada français mais la guerre a une
signification bien spéciale au québec
depuis les années sombres de 1917 où la
conscription a été imposée
c'est le dossier qui fait surface sans
arrêt alors son compromis c'est de
promettre un engagement fort et sans
équivoque du canada dans la guerre sauf
la conscription et les québécois ou
francophone lui font tout à fait
confiance ils n'ont guère le choix
nils continuelle selon aps avant les
boeufs venus très jeune
il était exactement 2 heures du matin
quand j'ai quitté l'avenue mon esprit et
mon cas était enfin au propos j'étais
très content parce que je savais que le
bien avait triomphé mackenzie king
remporte l'élection ou la main grâce au
québec avec 179 sièges sur 240 5 contre
36 pour le candidat conservateur mais le
canada s'engage à fond dans l'effort de
guerre et l'armée de volontaires ne
suffira pas la pression en faveur de la
conscription s'accroît
[Musique]
il se libère de sa promesse en 1942 par
un référendum approuvée à 80% par le
canada anglais mais rejetée à 80% par le
québec
mais king est prudent
king est un fin renard est dit parfait
j'ai une permission je mets cette
permission en poche au besoin la
conscription sera imposée mais pas
maintenant pas cette semaine pas le mois
prochain mais d'un trimestre à l'autre
ils traînent les choses et le nombre de
conscrits qui ont dû se rendent en
europe sur les champs de bataille ce
conte s'élèvent à quelques milliers
seulement le pire a été évité et les
francophones l'ont su
toute la journée j'étais certainement
guidé et du matériel m'est arrivé par
des mains invisibles qui n'avait déjà
apporter ce dont j'avais le plus besoin
lorsque j'étais là c'est très fatigué
dans l'accomplissement d'une grande page
[Musique]
ce n'est pas l'image d'un chef de guerre
qui nous est restée de mackenzie quai
mais celle que reflète son magnifique
domaine dans le parc de la gatineau où
se manifeste ce romantisme aspiré par
des ruines décoratives c'est là que
l'homme se promenait avec son chien
qu'il adorait ils croyaient dans le
spiritualisme de son ancien bureau de la
maison laurier à ottawa ce célibataire
endurci communiquer avec sa mère défunte
toutes sortes d'idées un peu étrange
mais il faisait un peu à part des choses
entre son mysticisme où sa vie
intérieure
j'en conviens assez particulière et sa
vie politique qu'il mène et de façon
très classique très très ordinaire
est-ce que les gens l'aimaient est-ce
qu'il était aimable
mais kenzy king c'est une personne qu'on
ne pouvait pas idolâtrer il était il
était belge il était ordinaire mais il
était comme ça il était sincèrement
comme ça et il s'en faisaient une vertu
vertus qui l'a maintenu au pouvoir
pendant 20 ans kenzy qui n'a su se
placer pendant la guerre parmi les
grands churchill et roosevelt qui l'a
accueilli à deux reprises à québec en
1941 et 1943 il est le petit fils de
william lane mais kenzy premier maire de
toronto et chef de la rébellion de 1837
dans le haut canada il a hérité de lui
un sens de son rôle dans l'histoire
comme lui mais plus subtilement il prend
progressivement ses distances de la mère
patrie ainsi le canada déclarent la
guerre à l'allemagne une semaine après
la grande bretagne le temps d'acheter
des quantités considérables d'armes aux
états unis encore neutre
[Musique]
héritage des dures années de guerre le
canada lui doit les allocations de
vieillesse l'état providence c'est lui
on lui doit aussi air canada et cybit si
radio canada
jazz trio
[Musique]
échappé
quand il a pris sa retraite finale en
1948 bien les choses étaient claires le
canada était un pays indépendant de
toutes les façons sauf pour une modalité
conceptionnelle qu'on connaît mais on
lui doit la citoyenneté canadienne
1947 et un de ses tout derniers héritage
auparavant on était sujets britanniques
vivant au canada avec king on peut
peut-être dire grâce à qui on devenait
citoyens canadiens à part entière on
peut maintenant dire que dorénavant le
canada tient sa place comme nation non
seulement parmi les nations du
commonwealth d'année mais comme nation
parmi les nations du monde une jeune
nation avec un et clarifie pas regard et
l'esprit de la jeunesse idéaliste
[Musique]
mackenzie king a à la fois été un chef
de guerre étonnant de la part de cet
homme placide et prudents et modérés on
est tout à fait surpris de la somme des
résultats et surtout il a réussi à
maintenir sans trop de déchirures un
climat national
relativement harmonieux ce qui n'est
jamais une mince affaire encore moins en
temps de guerre au canada je me rends
compte qu'on me trouverais by plus
affable dans mon entourage si je me
joignais vu en buvant me gratter sortie
de plaisir
heureusement j'ai choisi d'être libres
de tout désir de recherche du plaisir ou
de l'amour ayant une mission plus grand
à accomplir
cet homme plutôt terne à un peu
maladroit n'a pas inspiré beaucoup les
canadiens mais il a marqué profondément
et durablement le pays
[Musique]
non